the GH of boomerangs is a branch of the ice Factor
program in Adelaide as a program designed to uh
have kids who are slightly disengaged or having
issues at school just somewhere to have a bit
of an outlet before I joined ice hockey School
wasn't really my thing I just kept on getting in
trouble and then I came to ice socky and it made
me realize I kind of need someone else to help
me and get me through otherwise I'm not getting
through since I joined the boomerangs it's been a
really big Improvement and don't know what else
to do without them I guess we watch highlight
rails and we we talk about these players and
you know to actually be able to be out here
with them is just insane dream stuff for sure and
all these boys I know for the last week have been
on watching all the Highlight re and say there's
no way there's no way we're getting out with these
guys have said yeah yeah be nice I pr this pretty
often like maybe four or five times a week oh wow
that's almost as much as us good for you buddy
nice meeting you every Australian I've ever met
is amazing kind-hearted funny I never thought
I'd say I'd be playing hockey in Australia so
it's definitely privilege to be here what the
nhlpa goals and dreams have done for this long
bringing gear out here since 2008 and then giving
us the chance to finally come out here we're the
first NHL team to come to Australia so it's been a
great experience then to be on the ice with these
kids and actually see some of this firsthand it's
showing that hockey's really become a global sport
I'm a d you're d yeah nice setting the tone I love
it seeing kids in the First Nations Community take
up game of hockey we're really trying to spread
the gospel of hockey internationally so I'm hoping
these boys and girls are out here today are able
to get to see the coyotes and the Kings play up
close and then their love for the game you know
gets even deeper and deeper you want to spread
the game as much as you can the game's done so
much for me and so many other guys so if we can
get sticks in hands of players in different
countries that might not be familiar that's
what it's all about I made the artwork for a
more of a um cultural Exchange for sharing my
culture with you guys instead taking home a bit
of our country back and the culture here is just
so rich and it's breathtaking nice meeting you
thanks for the artwork good job someone made
this flag we'll hang it in our locker room and
do a little motivation for the next couple games
it's very very amazing to see that there are going
to be people who probably follow the game but now
they're going to see it on the big screen they're
going to know it's here at rodad Laver bringing
it to light in this country is really just it's
exactly what we need to heighten the sport for
me being here is something that I can share my
culture to it's special to me it's something I'm
going to hold to myself for a long for a long
time look I'm going to look back at [Applause]
it